I want to make you aware of some
breaking news the White House has
released a transcript of the u.s.
president Donald Trump's call with
Ukraine's president and it shows that he
did ask Ukraine's President to
investigate where the former Vice
President Joe Biden shut down an
investigation into a company where his
son worked that's according to a summary
of the call released by the Trump
administration let me quote from the
transcript that was released there's a
lot of talk about Biden's son that Biden
stopped the prosecution and a lot of
people want to find out about that so
whatever you can do with the attorney
general would be great President Trump
said in the call that's reading direct
there from that transcript provided by
the Justice Department Biden went around
bragging that he stopped the prosecution
so if you can look at in look into it it
sounds horrible to me he said so
repeated attempts to prod the Ukrainian
president into investigating former US
Vice President Joe Biden that breaking
news here we're getting in touch with
our correspondent Kimberly halket is on
Capitol Hill at for some live reaction
but in the meantime let's get a report
from Shahab returns he with the
background of all of this in Washington
DC it's been long reported that
Democratic House Majority Leader Nancy
Pelosi has been against impeachment
proceedings against Donald Trump
that has changed the actions of the
trump presidency revealed dishonorable
fact of the president's betrayal of his
oath of office betrayal of our national
security and betrayal of the integrity
of our elections therefore today I'm
announcing the House of Representatives
moving forward with an official
impeachment inquiry I'm directing our
six committees to proceed with their
investigations under that umbrella of
impeachment inquiry the president must
be held accountable no one is above the
law
Pelosi says two reasons convinced her to
launch the inquiry that President Trump
was allegedly asking the Ukrainian
president to investigate Democratic
rival Joe Biden and his son and that the
White House then prevented a
whistleblowers complaint about the
president's request to reach Congress as
required by law Pelosi is putting aside
her fair that an impeachment
investigation would allow President
Trump to mobilize his base with claims
of another witch-hunt
he maintains he's done nothing wrong and
authorized the release of a transcript
of his phone call with the Ukrainian
president zalenski shortly after Pelosi
spoke though Trump tweeted this
fundraising video ready to go containing
carefully curated sound bites from
Democratic politicians suggesting they
were attempting to subvert the will of
the people
if we don't impeach this president he
will get reelected it's time to stop
this nonsense
message amplified by the Republican
leader of the house I realize 2016 did
not turn out the way Speaker Pelosi
wanted it to happen but she cannot
change the laws of this Congress the
exact details of the way Ford for an
impeachment inquiry remain murky but
Pelosi said it will involve the findings
of the six inquiries already underway
into the president's alleged wrongdoing
the announcement may take the pressure
off the Democrats from their electoral
base increasingly angry about a lack of
action against the president now I think
what you'll see from Democrats is the
question is this gonna be a short
process or a longer process so a short
process means we look we we know what we
need to know we're not gonna do a lot of
investigating or not we're not going to
wait and turn over a lot of other stones
before we have this vote in the house to
impeach this guy and then the Senate
will either do or will do whatever it
does or doesn't do that's fine but then
by putting it behind Nancy Pelosi all of
those house candidates have said their
piece and now they can go on and talk
about other issues and not be hounded
about this the inquiry may also speed up
some of the judicial attempts underway
to get key information from Donald Trump
and his administration that so far
remains secret reports say Trump is
determined he will not be the third
president in US history to be impeached
and whatever the short-term political
consequences the opening of inquiry
doesn't mean Trump will eventually be
convicted of high crimes and
misdemeanors she AB Ratan C al Jazeera
Washington let's bring in a White House
correspondent than Kimberly halket is on
Capitol Hill the president then says
that this is all a garbage witch hunt
but the transcript Kimberly confirmed
the President did ask Ukraine's leader
to investigate Joe Biden not once at
least once right but what it doesn't
confirm is the second part of the
allegations against the president which
is that he was looking for a quid pro
quo in essence that he was looking for
in exchange for an investigation he was
holding back the promise of military aid
so on the one hand what I think we're
going to see here is the White House
saying look this transcript shows it's
not as incriminating as you suggest and
trying to play a bat but as you point
out it does show that the u.s. president
was urging the president of Ukraine to
employ an investigation against one of
his political rivals and that is what
the Democrats here in the House of
Representatives on Capitol Hill are
going to be focusing on this is what
Nancy Pelosi the Speaker of the House
said was the sort of turning point for
those moderate Democrats who were on the
fence about launching some sort of
impeachment proceeding against the
president so what happens now well the
the question becomes where this
investigation will lead we have six
committees that are all now under one
umbrella investigating the possibility
of impeachment but it comes down to a
vote in the House of Representatives and
that has not yet been called we also
have to remember for those who think
that this is going to lead to president
Trump immediately being removed from
office that's not a certainty either
because well the House of
Representatives which is controlled by
Democrats may favor impeaching the
president is the Senate that has to vote
to remove the president and that is
controlled by Republicans so this is
where things get a little bit unclear
about not only the speed of how this is
going to move but whether ultimately it
could lead to president Trump no longer
being the President of the United States
all right Kimberly many thanks indeed
White House correspondent Kimberly
Hellcat they're live at Capitol Hill